a happy marriage is a long conversation
which always seems too short
without a family
man alone in the world
trembles with the cold
conversation
would be vastly improved by the constant
use of four simple words
i
do not know
[Music]
we owe to the middle ages the two worst
inventions of humanity
romantic love
and gunpowder
happiness is never there to stay
happiness is merely a respite offered by
in quietude
smile
for everyone lacks self-confidence
and more than any other one thing
a smile reassures them
old is far more than white hair
wrinkles
a feeling that it is too late
and the game is finished
that the stage belongs to the rising
generations
the true evil is not the weakening of
the body
but the indifference of the soul
a successful marriage
is an edifice that must be rebuilt every
day
in literature
as in love
we are astonished at what is chosen by
others
there are certain persons for whom pure
truth
is a poison
the first recipe for happiness is
avoid too lengthy meditation on the past
growing old is no more than a bad habit
which a busy person has no time to form
[Music]
people are what you make them
a scornful look turns into a complete
fool
a man of average intelligence
a contemptuous indifference turns into
an enemy a woman who
well treated
might have been an angel
the effectiveness of work
increases according to geometric
progression
if there are no interruptions
[Music]
modesty and unselfishness
these are the virtues which men praise
and pass by
a marriage without conflicts is almost
as inconceivable
as a nation without crises
if men could regard the events of their
own lives with more open minds
they would frequently discover that they
did not really desire the things they
failed to obtain
to be witty
is not enough
one must possess sufficient wit to avoid
having too much of it
if you create an act
you create a habit
if you create a habit
you create a character
if you create a character
you create a destiny
[Music]
a true woman loves a strong man because
she knows his weaknesses
she protects as much as she is protected
above all things
never be afraid
the enemy who forces you to retreat is
himself afraid of you at that very
moment
we console ourselves with several
friends for not having found one real
one
men cheat because they don't feel needed
women because they don't feel loved
experience is valuable only when it has
brought suffering and when the suffering
has left its mark upon both body
and mind
[Music]